因为男朋友的话呢，
他也是做这个，
他才今年考了那个律师证，
他之前的话呢，
是跟他爸爸一起做一个吊顶，
就是那种装修方面的一个，
呃工作，
然后后面的话，
他在去年讲行，
他有一年的时间，
然后就是自学法律这一方面，
本科是学的金融，
然后现在目前的话呢，
相当于去年也没有收入，
但大家可能就是已经在实习了，
去年他考的是一个C证，
今年的话他把A证考到了，
现在实习大概是3000块钱左右一个月的工资，
我现在目前的话呢，
我跟他他已经谈了两年半了，
现在目的就非常纠结两个人要不要结婚的这个问题，
其实我是不不太了解，
就是作为律师的话，
就是入行之后，
他到底未来就是他的一个收入状况是什么样子，
因为就是两个人都是属于农村家庭出身，
是没有什么背景的，
然后的话呢，
他现在目前要跟爸爸妈妈还有奶奶，
就是住一套比较小的房子，
目前的工资状态是很不稳定的嘛，
就3000块钱一个月，
因为我自己的话，
像做房产这一块，
可能从现在来看是可以的，
但是长远的话也不是那么稳定，
自己可能赚个一年可能二三十万是没有什么太大问题的，
他今年是多大了，
我。
是94年的，
他是九一年的，
大概是34岁了，
就在这个阶段去转行，
就他们就分到的这个点，
这样子代因我理解你就以说他现在这个状态，
作为一个实习的律师，
一个月3000多块钱，
让你觉得未来就是不知道，
不知道有太多不确定的因素，
不知道他未来能不能干成，
能不能干成大律师，
能不能在律师这个行业里面挣到很多很多的钱，
但这个事儿呢，
我跟你说律师啊，
能不能挣到钱，
这个真得看这个律师他本人的性格，
他本人的钻研能力，
本人明系社会关系的能力，
他本人开拓案研的能力，
他本人身上具不具那样的气质，
让别人可以相信他有这个实力，
能干成这个事儿的那个气质，
这个东西的话，
可能就是你自己客观的去评价一下，
第一就他的社交能力怎么样，
维系客户资源的能力怎么样，
第二他本身的父辈的社交能力怎么样。
啊，
父辈有没有足够多认识的朋友啊，
资源啊之类的，
第三包括你如果你是做房地产的，
通讯录里大概有多少人，
有多少人知道你的老公是律师，
这些东西对他来说，
将来都可能为他产生案源。
其实一个律师他能不能吃上这碗饭，
能不能挣着这个钱，
取决于有多少人知道他是一个律师，
有多少人知道他是一个干什么什么专业的律师，
有多少人相信他的专业能力是OK的，
当然也取决于他自己选择什么样的专业领域。
一般情况下，
刚起步的律师可能很难上来就选择一个，
比如我就专门干婚姻啊，
张三就专门干刑事，
王五就专门干交通肇事，
李四就专门干那个什么。
呃，
公司股权纠纷，
刚起步的律师很难做到这一点，
他可能要工作个三年5载之后，
慢慢的他在某一个方面，
比如说他，
呃，
积累了一定的客户资源了，
他才会选择这个专业，
所以你要问我说你的老公将来啊，
能不能干成，
可能一方面取决于他的社交能力，
他的专业上自己愿意下功夫的程度，
也取决于他跟了一个什么样的师傅，
他跟的那个师傅愿不愿意把他的客户资源，
这个叫什么艺术。
铺的这个客户资源，
自己做不过来的案子，
甩给他来做，
也取决于他在跟他的师傅，
跟他的前辈们相处的时候，
懂不懂事儿，
这背后就是说师傅和前辈是不会白白给你们安缘的，
这个大家理解吗？
嗯嗯，
这一切都是人情世故，
就是说你的这个老公他能不能挣着钱，
不光取决于他是不是有个律师本儿，
还决于他懂不懂人情世故，
情商高不高，
懂不懂得维系这些关系，
懂不懂得开发自己的客户，
包括你将来如果说你的客户资源特别广的话，
你多带你老公出去社交啊什么的，
让你身边的同事、
朋友，
呃，
亲戚、
客户都知道你老公是干哪一块业务的，
对他来说也是一种助力，
也是一种帮助。
一旦这些东西打通了之后，
像长沙那样的地方，
一个律师啊，
年收入，
呃，
就是普普通通的律师，
我觉得年收入搞个二十万三十万应该是问题不大的，
嗯，
就是我有一次就跟着他一起去看，
他去开多元，
其实我觉得是真的是最最最最没有方法的方法，
他以他到医院里面去一户一户的问啊，
就是你这边的话是怎么受伤的，
你这边的话是不需要律师，
就是援助之类的，
就是一个一个的问，
我当时还给他提建议，
我说你一定要印自己的名片。
如果他现在没有，
他可能后续有需要，
有生的有朋友需要，
他可以联系到你，
他没有去做下兼职做下来，
然后的话，
我说你可以在网上去做一些宣传啊，
然后把朋友圈经营起来啊，
不是他他都没有，
他觉得这个东西他是律师，
他不是销售，
他不不屑于去做这些事情，
我觉得，
但是你想搞钱的话，
那你肯定是要，
就是拼尽自己的全力所用自己的能够用的所有的方法去推广自己，
对不对，
但是他没有，
所以我觉得其实像我菲姐说的，
就是说他对这个半人开拓的能力，
以及他的一个社交的能力，
我是没有看到的，
他我跟他在一起两年半了，
我从来没有见过他一个朋友，
他从来没有带我去见过他的一个朋友，
那其实说到父辈的话，
农村家庭出生，
现在目前爸爸妈妈已经基本上都是60多岁了，
没有什么收入，
可能爸爸只有3000块钱左右的一个退休金呢，
就是家庭没有办法给他，
他就是资源方面的一个助力，
你没有办法给到他经济方面的一个助力，
所以其实这个话让我很恐慌。
我自己相对来说，
我是属于就是一毕业就在做房地产，
我自己可能大概也有个200左右的样子，
按照他那天我跟他算了一下，
他可能大概可能自己赚到手，
估计也就是五六十的样子吧，
就是加上他的房子和车子的这些年的开销，
大概就是这么多，
反正我只能看到这么多吧，
就是他自己的现在的这个资产状况，
和你比起来的话，
他比你差一大截是吧，
你有200万的存款，
他那边的资产加起来的话大概是五六十万，
是这样吗？
对，
主要是我觉得就是如果说他是一个就是很上进的人，
然后的话呢，
他或者说我，
我能够看到他很有未来，
我也觉得你现在苦一点，
我也能够接受，
对吧，
但是的话，
我现在目前就是很慌张的，
就是家庭给不了助力，
然后他自己这边的话呢，
就感觉不是那么的上进，
就像您说的，
那他到时候未来到底靠不靠谱，
你就按照现在目前他说他可能嗯，
现在目前自己没有接触太多的爱人，
明年可能做一年授薪律师，
那可能大概可能工资五六千左右的样子，
那如果说我要是跟他生一个小孩，
他可能都还没有办法养家，
那还要我怀着孕，
然后去赚钱养家。
那还是说在他爸爸妈妈身体都非常健康的情况下面，
那如果说他爸爸妈妈要是身体稍微有一点点，
那是有点问题啊，
那他可能都还是要我去填补他们家的亏空吧，
我就觉得很困扰，
就我自己其实属于就是比较可能是原生家庭，
比较缺爱那种留守儿童啊，
然后的话呢，
从小奶奶大大的，
我自己比较缺爱，
而且的话，
嗯，
奶奶有那种重男轻女的现象，
所以的话，
我自己也是属于那种非常要强的，
就是希望能够不断去证明自己，
对我自己的一个就是赚钱的一个积极性还是很强的，
但是他一般般，
他的优点就是他能够就是比较愿意花时间去陪伴我，
我是缺乏陪伴，
对我相对来说是非常包容的，
我纠结了很久，
中间其实我想过，
就是如果从理性的方面来考虑，
我是真的不太愿意去跟他结婚了，
现在目前一个年龄大了，
两边父母都在催，
但是我在想，
如果说我要是跟他结婚的话，
我要是觉得后面我又过不下去，
那我离婚，
那我不成了，
现在还是单身女青年对吧？
那到时候是单身的大龄单身二婚那不更惨对吧？
我我刚刚你问我的关于他有没有前途这件事情，
我已经跟你描述的很清楚了，
一个律师。
有没有权前途他真的取决于很多因素，
然后你是离他最近的那个人，
你自己去判断啊，
他具不具备一个成功律师所具备的那些因素，
如果你认为不具备，
你自己权衡好，
好吧，
你自己条件很好，
就是你自己30岁的年纪，
能有200万的存款，
你已经打败了可能99.9%的女性，
所以你自己要主宰你自己的婚姻，
主宰你自己未来的这样一个生活，
嗯，
还有一个我想问就是其实像我这种的话，
就是做销售的话，
可能现在赚钱，
但是未来可能是肯定是在有下坡路的随生年龄，
但是的话，
律师他可能未来的话是会有慢慢随着他的资历啊，
年龄啊，
然后会往上走的，
你有没有考虑过，
就如果啊，
你们俩双线合璧，
比如说你现在是做销售的啊，
房地产这个行业已经不景气了，
你早晚是要转型的，
有没有可能你作为那个开拓案源的人，
而他作为那个承接案源的人，
我没有涉猎这一块，
就是不过我也自己也有考虑过，
就是在接待客户的时候，
偶尔可能也可以聊一聊，
然后的话可能有这方面的需求的时候，
也可以帮忙去发展一下，
我给你举一个例子啊，
这个例子可能未必。
很恰当，
其实我的同行里面有一个律师叫刘胜飞律师，
他是属于非常专业，
非常专注的那样的律师，
他的老婆就是在给他做律师的，
相当于助手，
一方面就是帮助他在拓展案源，
另一方面也在帮助他解决客户的一些比如说啊心理问题啊，
各方面的问题，
他们两口子就配合的挺好，
当然他老婆是学那种，
呃，
社会的，
像你是学销售的，
其实学销售的人啊，
我个人是非常尊敬的，
因为我觉得任何一个行业都离不开销售，
任何一个行业其实挣钱多的都是销售，
在销售的过程当中积累的这些经验和销售的技巧，
在任何一个行业他都是能够起到一定的帮助的，
就是如果说你和现在的这个老公，
如果能够拧成一股绳，
在他不太擅长拓展案源，
不太擅长拓展人际关系，
而你又擅长拓展人际关系的时候的话，
其实你俩可能会形成一个比较稳固的这样一个家庭利益结合体，
因为销售在律师这个行业的话，
他也是，
呃，
拿他该拿的钱的，
我话只能点到这儿，
你能够谈回来的客户，
你也是拿钱的，
那是一种合作的关系，
嗯，
仅供你参考，
是一个思路啊，
就如果说你没有更好的选择，
没有更好的选项的时候，
你就要转。
定思路，
要把你的价值和你老公将来的老公的价值能够发挥到更大啊，
发挥到互补，
嗯，
但是如果说他人就是抛开亲济方面来看的话，
他也没有什么不良嗜好啊，
对我也还好，
那他也是一个，
就是如果说我们就是确实家人家人齐心，
其利断金嘛，
对吧，
就是如果说大家都往一个方向去去发展的话，
那也是一个可以的结婚对象吗？
是一个思路，
而且在这个过程当中的话，
你也依赖他，
他也依赖你，
反而你们两口子之间可能会形成一种非常紧密的利益关系，
嗯。
嗯，
好吧，
供你参考这个思路啊，
好好，
我就这样，
他拜拜，
嗯，
然后我多说两句啊，
就是你自己婚前的这200万存款，
你要保护好是吧，
你单独放到一张卡里，
你存定期也好，
你干嘛也好，
呃，
大额存单也好，
都可以，
那就婚前的200万就是你的个人财产，
这样的话，
你无论跟谁结婚，
你都会有一个退步，
你都会有一个自己的这样一个退路。